El partido popular y en general la derecha,
ha utilizado muchísimas ocasiones
el tema de los fondos NES generation
para atizar para atacar al gobierno de coalición
y en estos últimos días,
pues hemos tenido a cuca Gamarra,
la Secretaría general del partido popular
que se ha metido con el gobierno en general
también con los fondos next generation,
los fondos de recuperación,
hablando de que lo reciben fundamentalmente
administraciones públicas,
que por lo tanto
esto es como 1 especie de financiarse a sí mismo, ¿no?
Algo así ha dicho.
Ahora lo veremos y como digo eso es 1 estupidez,
es 1 chorrada porque lo vais a ver a continuación.
Pero esto ocurre en todas las partes de Europa,
no es algo lo que
lo que solo se beneficie
en las administraciones públicas
y por si fuera poco,
1 de los ayuntamientos más beneficiados de todos
es el de Madrid,
o sea que es del partido popular,
o sea que se está tirando piedras sobre su propio.
Este tema, pues es así,
no es muy relevante, desde luego,
pero da para hablar sobre cómo funciona 1 poquito
los fondos generation,
porque hay gente que no tiene ni idea y lo que dice ah
dinero por aquí se autofinancia como cuca Gamarra.
Bueno, vamos a poner seriedad en este asunto